malgré la connaissance qu'ils avaient
des risques encourus depuis de très
nombreuses années qu'ils n'ont jamais
pris les mesures qui s'imposaient et
ainsi tromper les consommateurs du
médiator les mots de la présidente du
tribunal correctionnel ce matin les
laboratoires servier ont été condamné
pour tromperie aggravée homicides et
blessures involontaires condamné
également l' agence de sécurité du
médicament pour ne pas avoir rempli son
rôle
le médiator utilisé par des millions de
malades jusqu'à son retrait du marché en
2009 il avait provoqué la mort de
centaines de personnes
le jugement était très attendue dans
cette affaire l'un des pires scandales
sanitaires français au tribunal de paris
on retrouve notre reporter katia
technique dans le laboratoire services
et six filiales ont été condamné pour
tromperie aggravée et blessures et
homicides involontaires condamné à la
somme de deux millions sept cent
dix-huit mille euros quant au numéro 2
des laboratoires servier jean philippe
seta
il a été condamné à quatre ans de prison
mais avec sursis et à plus de 90000
euros damende mais les sociétés de
servier de bon en outre régler une forte
indemnité aux parties civiles à 158
millions d'euros et jean philippe seta
devra lui s'acquitter de la somme de 12
millions d'euros
je vous propose d'écouter la réaction de
l'avocat des laboratoires servier
françois de castro
sur le plan des indemnisations elles me
paraissent elles me paraissent élevées
en ce qui concerne le préjudice moral
puisqu'il s'agit de préjudice moral pur
manifestement le tribunal est allé
au-delà de ce qu'on voit habituellement
dans ce type d'affaires mais encore une
fois l'action civile c'est une chose qui
compte c'est l'action publique et si
celles qui concernent les infractions
qui sont reprochés donc il y a comme
vous l'avez vu des relaxes nombreuses
qui ont été prononcées par le tribunal
et il y à une condamnation pour
l'essentiel de tromperie aggravée
on va devoir regarder sans détails le
tribunal a blâmé ce matin des faits
d'une extrême gravité il faut savoir que
des centaines de personnes seraient
mortes à cause de leur consommation de
médiator et il allait
céder ces cas là des milliers d'autres
1,6500 partie civile lors de ce procès
pour autant les réquisitions du parquet
avait été bien plus sévère 10 millions
d'euros et cinq ans de prison dont trois
seulement avec sursis pour jean philippe
seta je propose d'écouter un des avocats
des parties civiles est une victime
michel du jeu rappelle que le groupe les
laboratoires servier c'est 10 millions
d'euros par jour
donc vous voyez que l'amande qui est
ordonnée elle est extrêmement faible
elle est non significative ensuite sur
le montant des dommages et intérêts qui
sont accordées aux victimes
là aussi les dommages et intérêts sont
très faibles notre cousin j'ai déjà dit
ça va pas on fait un peu de tout de
suite moi je fais appel
ou alors je vais beaucoup plus loin ils
ont gâté ma vie bien dit il était écouté
je me suis marié les 24 février 73
m'appuierai 47 ans d'accord 20 48 en
mode mais savait que janvier pour opérer
le 24 février 2011 l' agence nationale
du médicament a quant à elle été
condamnée à 300 3000 euros damende la
présidente a estimé que l'institution
avait fait preuve de fragilité de
mauvaises analyses alors qu'elle
disposait de tous les éléments pour
retirer le médicament de la vente s
enfin les pilotes pour cette affaire dix
ans après le scandale et bien non
puisque certains avocats des parties
civiles ont annoncé leur intention de
faire appel